all right uh let's get to the game that
finished the day and it's funny as we
watch the games we prioritize what are
we going to talk about first what are we
going to talk about first and there's
always that possibility sunday night
football is going to trump everything
and last night it did
37-34 in overtime and i'll tell you i
was feeling good about pulling what i
call the hole in one when you pick the
score exactly i had seahawks 34
cardinals 27. it's 34-24 they're lining
up for the field goal they make the
field goal 34-27 oh but wait the
leverage penalty extended that drive
that was the turning point that was the
moment that the door opened for the
cardinals because they parlayed that
into a touchdown
that that made it a three-point game and
then to their defense's credit their
much-maligned defense's credit yeah shut
them down the rest of the way in
regulation overtime twice
stop the seahawks and russell wilson
twice in overtime are you kidding me
right and then and then they get the the
walk off to win it with 15 seconds left
in overtime i thought we're gonna have a
tie i'm glad there wasn't a tie it was
an exciting game to watch and it was
great to see kyle murray get the win
over his boyhood idol yeah well it
definitely is i mean he's just an
exciting player to watch i mean that was
a fun game to watch because the two
quarterbacks yeah they can beat you in
the pocket doing all those things but
it's all the off schedule crazy
playmaking stuff they do and the and the
jams they get out of consistently you
know throughout the game i mean mike
you're right that was a huge moment of
the game because it's you know it's just
going to be a different story where oh
we kick a field goal
now
all right we're going to have to kick
the ball off to seattle yeah we might
have our timeouts and blah blah blah but
at the same time
yeah you're still going to have to go
score a touchdown and you know i guess i
look at seattle a little bit too at the
end of the football game especially the
end of regulation one of the things that
jumps out to me you know we've had this
conversation through the years with
other great quarterbacks you know what
why why the foot off the gas pedal so
much you know the team is built around
the offense and all of a sudden we know
the defense stinks it stinks they're
coming back it stinks it stinks
oh let's run the ball and see if our
defense can make a stop wha what no your
defense is having trouble making any
stops all year long i was a little
surprised by that at the end of the game
especially when we got into the third
and two situation that at least we
didn't see a russell wilson anything
just the ball in his hands run throw
whatever it may be he's the best player
on the team he's the best player in the
field he comes through that way i just
shot i was a little shocked by that
approach by the seahawks at the end
let me make an observation that just
crystallized because i was as i was
watching the game last night
russell wilson seemed
less explosive
to me than usual right
and i think it's because he was playing
tyler murray that's exactly
when you put him on the same field with
kyle murray on the same night all of a
sudden the stuff russell wilson does
doesn't seem as special as it does
against a tom brady or somebody who has
less mobility but he wasn't as zip away
and gone right you saw him get swallowed
up
several times which is is
uncharacteristic anyway but it's even
more uncharacteristic on a night where
there are 48 passes thrown by kyler
murray and he doesn't get hit a single
time because they cannot touch him
no well i mean mike i mean russell
wilson's fast he's not on the same level
as kyla murray i mean kyla murray is
you know i i mean him michael vick
lamar jackson they're the three fastest
quarterbacks ever there's no doubt about
that and as far as acceleration is
concerned i don't know if anybody can
accelerate the way kyla murray can i
mean i'm talking about anybody i don't
care receivers in the nfl whoever his
first three steps and his ability to get
10 15 yards down the field in those
three or four steps it's unmatched i
mean that is superstar acceleration so
i'm with you from that standpoint
there's no doubt about that but you know
nonetheless hey arizona's for real mike
your like proclamation about back in
march about maybe four teams in the nfc
west going to the playoffs i mean it's
starting to like maybe look like it
could be a real possibility uh because
they haven't even started to play each
other all yet either which is going to
be interesting as we go forward but the
game itself man couldn't have been
better
and
vance joseph and that defense settled in
on russell wilson that last quarter and
a half over time and they gave them some
issues schematically physically
everything like that so you got to give
them credit along with kylie murray
oh they had the fake blitz that oh
yeah that that gave arizona i mean it
looked like it was going to be either
seattle's going to win or it's going to
be a tie yeah for arizona to get the
ball back late
piece together just enough to get in
position to win the game that was him
everything about that game was amazing
and
i you get spoiled by games like that
because you want more you know you see
you just want to inject it into your
veins every time you turn on a football
game it is a non-stop thrill ride and
yeah it's a lot of points but so what
it's fun to watch and it's fun to watch
two great quarterbacks and and you know
with kyler murray like how many times
this year are we going to see the play
and and look they should i mean it's not
a criticism but he drops back he gets
pressure he sees a crack to his left he
slips through it he sprints up the
sideline and he stops on a dime and
steps out of bounds i mean i i've seen
that like two or three times already
this year
and and it's unstoppable it it just
comes down to he is so good he is so
fast i said this last monday night
watching the game against the cowboys i
put it on twitter he's got speed agility
and awareness combined that we've never
seen before you're like what about
michael vick what about lamar jackson
they don't have the awareness this kid
has vic got hit vic got hurt lamar
jackson gets hit he's gonna get hurt
murray doesn't get touched no because he
knows exactly where he is he knows
exactly where everyone else is
and he knows how to hit the ground he
got hit one time and i think this is
what freaked out one he got hit solid
one time in overtime right and i think
that's what freaked out cliff kingsbury
and got him to send out the field goal
the one that he ultimately missed the 41
yarder he's like okay enough let's get
out of here and when they should have
taken more of overtime when they should
have gotten the ball closer
and and ultimately missed the field goal
and extended overtime well the very
least you you bleed out the time to make
the other team have to use their
timeouts right that's where they messed
up in that situation all together uh but
it's amazing how much happened in that
last two and a half minutes it is it
really is yeah i mean through with three
you know a field goal try that was
missed a drive that was almost in field
goal range and then a drive that ends
the game with the walk-off it's and if
the game took like what four hours but i
don't mind i'll take six hours for a
game like that yeah i i get it i mean it
wasn't it wasn't void of action or
anything like that now it was void of
defense at times i'll say that that's
where i don't always love it and again
you know that's where it's going to be
interesting with seattle as we go here
because it just doesn't matter who they
play you could see they have a hard time
putting the game away putting any team
away their defense can't make plays that
way and you know we'll see jamal adams
being back i think would tell a
different story in that football game
altogether and i even think chris carson
losing him through the game that hurt
them as well especially when it comes to
oh we're up by 10 and now we need our
sledgehammer to run the ball i gotta i
mean i hyde is a good runner
and i'm not trying to take anything away
from him but chris carson's special in
those moments that's part of what he is
too so those you know those will be two
different things that the cardinals have
to face the next time around but
nonetheless i think this kind of
solidifies
arizona to where one of those teams
where i was like i'm not sure
are they gonna
hang on here and maybe be in playoff
contention or are they going to fall
apart and not make it i think last night
gives you enough evidence to go wait
there's some fight and the toughness in
the football team to where they're going
to be in this in the long haul we'll
just see where it shakes out
they're and two through seven games last
year they were five ten and one through
sixteen so great
improvement by the cardinals and they're
right in the thick of things and and you
know i i think the big winner we're
gonna talk about their game coming up is
the buccaneers because i think they're
the team now that that you look at in
the nfc is the most balanced the most
complete no doubt and the most likely to
emerge and look there's still a lot of
football to be played but as of right
now i'd say the most likely to emerge
from that group of 16 teams in the nfc
the the drive that tied the game yeah
saw larry fitzgerald do exactly the same
thing that he did at the end of the
first half in week one where they're
they're moving
the clock is ticking
the half is almost over in this case the
game was almost over and they were down
three points right a tackle is made on a
moving clock he picks up he grabs the
ball from the teammate and sprints to
the middle of the field hands it to the
official it gets set and they're able to
get everyone in position
snap the ball and spike it with time
left on the clock that that and
i saw someone make the point last night
you know it just shows how how rare it
is in football for guys to have a high
iq level because it's so glaring when
there is a guy like larry fitzgerald i
mean everyone should know that's what
you do
but to be able to do it and apply it in
that moment
when everything else is happening around
you is what makes it special it's easy
for us to say they got to set the ball
they got to snap the ball they got to
spike the ball but when you're down
there in the in the you know crux of
bodies
it's it's not as easy to do well
fitzgerald is always aware of the
situation unlike any other guy that i've
seen in recent years yeah well it's it's
what makes great players great they have
a calmness and ability to slow the game
down in their mind to where
you know they're just not flustered by
the moment the you know the scrutiny the
the intensity in the building about
where they are and yeah you know most
times most times plays like that guys
get up in a frenzy and wait oh we gotta
clock the ball right and they just drop
the ball because they got to worry about
where do i gotta line up and okay now
i've done that but yeah when you drop
the ball now the ref had to run another
three seconds to go get that ball and
flip it to his buddy and do all that
stuff to where yeah he's been there done
that he doesn't lose his cool he grabs
the ball he runs right over there that's
it but yeah it's little things like that
you know deandre hopkins some of the
catches he made you know you get kyler
murray kenyon drake i will see where he
is you know but him chase edmonds in the
backfield man they got some little duo
of running backs and people you have to
worry about on their offense and their
defense which is not great but obviously
made some plays last night and we see
some playmakers out there that can give
kyla murray an extra position possession
or two and he'll make plays and keep
them in games or win games or whatever
that may be but
it's not my favorite formula in the
world as far as arizona is concerned but
damn they're good and they know how to
work it
you mentioned kenyon drake he was carted
off late in the game so that's going to
be very concerning and it makes you
wonder
and and look they moved the trade
deadline several years ago from the
tuesday after week six to the tuesday
after week eight this is week seven that
just unfolded
will the cardinals they made a trade the
other day to beef up their defense and
marcus golden right will they make some
sort of a deal or try to make some sort
of a deal to uh to to replace kenyon
drake if it is an extended injury i look
back at their schedule and you know
they've now begun
and most recently finished with wins in
the division beating the 49ers yeah in
san francisco and then beating the
seahawks in arizona
they beat washington 30 to 15. the
losses become glaring though when you
see how good this team can be to lose to
the lions right to lose to the panthers
by 10 points they turned it around after
that blew out the jets blew out the
cowboys this really don't give me bingo
for this this is a legitimate point
we're trying to make here people this is
the this is i i and they go into their
buy now they get two weeks to piece it
together but you know good teams win the
games they're supposed to win
and and and i i hope they don't regret
later in the year when it's time to see
where everybody fits together and apply
tiebreakers that that they look back on
that lions and panthers
double header and say
what the hell did we do to ourselves
there that's that's i hear you that's
why listen i'm not sold on arizona i
know they won last night i did i i get
it but i just still have not there's
something about the football team in
general and i think a little bit is
probably i'm scarred by the schedule a
little bit you know you talk about the
jets blowout hey that was 17 10 in the
fourth quarter it's kind of a sneaky not
really a blowout but we made two plays
at the end of the game to make it look
like that so we all feel better about it
that way hey obviously whoop the crap
out of the cowboys but had some
struggles there you know i just i don't
i don't know what it is about the
football team i guess what i'm saying
really is you know they feasted on
really some bad defenses here as of late
uh okay and what i just think about i
think long term what i worry about is
you know again moments of staleness with
their offense and just so much being on
kyler murray having to make the play
have to make the scramble do all that i
just wonder if sustainable that's where
i i really i think again they'll get
away with it a lot of the against the
middle class and those type of football
teams but
you know i you know i just i don't know
there's some element about their team
and their style they play to where i'm
just not bought in yet to go
like oh yeah maybe they're a playoff
football team but i don't feel like they
can make a real run in the playoffs
quite yet does that make sense
i i it does and we're gonna learn a lot
get ready to put the bingo sign up again
because after the bye week they got some
games coming bills yeah right dolphins
and bills
at seattle right on a thursday night
short week and you know the seahawks are
going to be ready for them that time
then at the patriots
finally the rams the next five games for
them although at the patriots not as
daunting as it uh may have previously
seemed we talking about that as well
coming up for now chris last thing from
last night's game the dk metcalf play
running down buddha baker buda baker
makes the interception that in any other
situation is a pick six nobody's
touching the defensive back when he's
got a head of steam grabs the flat pass
takes off the other way it's always a
pick six right
except when dk metcalf is on the field
and he came out of
nowhere and it became obvious he was
going to catch buda baker and you could
tell from buda baker's body language
he's like oh my god really this guy's
here he's there he's going to get me and
he got him i mean look at this here
comes 14 and it's just inevitable he
runs right by russell wilson
right there man and my goodness dragged
him down and they ended up not scoring
anything on that drive right nothing
nothing no i know well that was an
egregious interception you know really
russell wilson's first
two in you know his first two
interceptions were egregious last night
but they were followed up by
arizona not kicking the field goal there
so they lost seven points in that
scenario and then russell wilson with
the other interceptions he scrambled to
his right i think early in the fourth
quarter or whatever that was hey then
kyla murray led him off the hook and
threw an interception in the next play
either way but dk metcalf i mean yeah
it's him
you know tyree kill
terry mclaurin there's only like a
handful of guys in football they're
gonna chase down buddha baker buddha
baker it's not like he's slow he can run
you know so that was special i mean the
way he turns it on and his knees start
going up in the air and he starts high
stepping to run after people wow but the
bigger thing is this mike where the hell
was he the other 70 minutes of the
football game that's what i don't
understand with the seattle last night
why why did we wait till overtime to
throw him to a screen a screen like why
wasn't he giving a reverse and had seven
screens at that point well
that to me was a little troubling as the
game went on it really seemed like vance
joseph and arizona started to lock down
what seattle wanted to do and i'll be
interested to watch that film and
everything like that but i'm shocked
that he was kind of muted like that that
way
tyler lockett had 200 yards too though
so i know russell wilson was taking what
was there right but you're right at a
certain point there are ways to design
plays to get the ball to dk metcalf
maybe that's where they're at in the
evolution of his career he's a guy that
you have to design plays to get him the
ball because he he look we saw it in
their last game two weeks ago the sunday
night game against the vikings he he he
had that mentality i want to win the
game get me the ball yeah and and i
thought we saw that until the david
moore holding penalty called it back
right but yeah get that guy the ball and
let him do his thing because once he
gets going no one can catch him all
right we have an atlanta meme i guess
because the falcons blew their
or the seahawks rather blew a 10-point
lead what do we got oh there oh that's
it that
means of all this right yes yes that's
good i like that and hey speaking of
blown leads
kylo ren this is a highly specific stat
but i've always i'm always fascinated by
this the nfl research twitter feed i
noticed this earlier today
kyler murray is only the second
quarterback ever to throw three or more
touchdown passes and erase a ten point
fourth quarter deficit when facing
russell wilson do you know who the other
was oh well all right so wait he's the
only one there's only one other that's
it only one other three or more
touchdown passes for the game and
erasing a ten point fourth quarter
deficit against russell wilson well that
would be super bowl 49 and tom brady
right yes exactly that's the only other
time it's happened thank you
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports